hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Jun is here to hit you in the face with
brand-new video games for ps4 Xbox one
PC and switch the biggest news though is
that Ghost of Tsushima has been delayed
by one month into July but if that's the
worst of our troubles I think we're
gonna be just fine here's seven new
games and a bunch of DLC releasing in
June 2020 and I found a couple of free
games to help keep your money in your
pockets one is so weird
but we'll get to that soon enough let's
do this like I was gonna start anywhere
else it's time to experience the Last of
Us part two seven years ago the original
game released and is firmly one of the
best video games ever made in terms of
mature storytelling in a world which is
cutthroat and deadly will be picking up
where we left off well sort of five
years have passed effectively the Last
of Us part 2 is a survival horror
adventure title following a 19 year old
Ellie in her pursuit of vengeance the
core gameplay loop here is stealth and
covert movement trying not to be noticed
added to this time around by a prone
mechanic allowing Ellie to lay and crawl
around encounters hopefully leading to
an opening to take down an enemy without
alerting the others Ellie is not the
only one to have evolved the enemies now
have guard dogs which you smell to find
Ellie wherever she is hiding but of
course we are not forced to hide in the
shadows Ellie can fight with improvised
weaponry and firearm skills to be
battle-ready in any circumstance I'll be
breaking down everything you need to
know next week including a breakdown of
the original game's story The Last of Us
part 2 releases June 19th and we are
promised this is really it the real
release date this time it won't move
again hopefully also I know you know
this but this is a ps4 exclusive so
expect some bad eggs who can't play the
game to try and spoil it for you so stay
vigilant
most people here though are pretty cool
hopefully
[Music]
next a brand-new game all the way from
2003 Sponge Bob Squarepants battle for
bikini bottom 17 years after the ps2 and
GameCube original released comes the
remaster inspirationally adding
rehydrated to the title back in 2003
Sponge Bob Squarepants battle for bikini
bottom man that's a long title
anyway back and forth back then this
game was much like Spyro or Crash
Bandicoot in design a 3d platformer with
more collectibles than you can imagine
right this very moment they did
everything very well including a
character switching mechanic using bus
stops to play our spongebob Patrick and
Sandy all of that has been retained in
the 20/20 remaster with noticeable
additions - such as a multiplayer hard
mode which can be played in cooperation
or against each other both locally and
online what's most impressive to me is
the addition of previously cut content
from 2003 like boss battles dream
sequences and the new bad guy to find if
you played the crash bandicoot remasters
you might want to check out this series
spongebob squarepants battle for bikini
bottom rehydrated drops on June 23rd on
ps4 Xbox one PC and switch
[Music]
next we have a free-to-play game which
is really really really strange this is
Island saver where do I start with this
one island saver is an educational game
published by a bank a real life
international banking PLC still
interested good setting first person we
begin life on a group of islands but
there is one serious problem here
plastic waste and rubbish has washed up
on your beaches and you must cleanse the
island to bring back the animal life
luckily for you you have trash blasters
like a water gun of hope this game is
designed to teach kids about caring for
the planet but also get this banking
yeah each animal you help award coins
and one in ten coins are taken by the
tax man he literally turns up and takes
money from you I honestly wish I knew
about this stuff before I became an
adult understanding that the money you
earn is partially taken away from you
every week month or year well stand you
in good stead when you get older okay
the teacher in me is making far too much
noise now featuring 42 banker moles to
save you get it Bank animals banker
moles across jungle ice desert and
volcanic biomes and helping a kiwi bird
find her missing eggs island saver is
like journey to the savage planet and
job simulator rolled into one
if you haven't switched off already
Pilon saber is available right now on
ps4 PC Xbox and twitch all for free
another free game releasing in June is
violent this is PC only I'm afraid which
is a bit of a bummer but it's clear
violent is a hardcore tactical shooter
in the same vein as Counter Strike
global Offensive the twist here is that
it has hero shooter elements like
overwatch where each operative has
different skills and abilities we take
control of an agent and buy weapons
using the in-game economy system with
sidearms shotguns snipers assault rifles
all the firearms you'd expect to choose
the better you play the more money you
accrue one team defends a bomb site
whilst the other attempt to plant a bomb
before the round ends or to win quicker
than that defeat the entire opposition
team this will quickly become a Protea
game meaning casual audiences with
controllers shouldn't expect to play
this soon but - money talks and
according to newspaper reports initial
exploration to bring valor into mobile
and console have begun I'll let you know
if anything happens there valor int
releases on June 2nd only on PC
[Music]
next we have a sci-fi shooter in the
shape of disintegration releasing on
June 16th this is far more than a simple
first-person shooter disintegration
mixes mech like battles with intricate
accuracy and enough tactical elements to
make this honestly a real-time strategy
game of sorts - simply put
disintegration is dense taking
inspiration from multiple genres coming
from the mind of one of the Halo
creators it's easy to see where the
visual elements were founded and that's
where the halo vibes stop in a world
filled with augmented robot humans
controlling huge mechanical weapons and
those who remain natural and fight with
standard weaponry the hook of
disintegration is the ability to direct
ground troops who are extremely fragile
whilst protecting them from the air in
frantic battles coordinating with other
players to reign supreme in frantic
multiplayer battles I'll go out alone in
a single-player story driven campaign
it's an extremely unique take on both
first-person shooters and realtime
strategy games which may be a little too
complicated for many of us at first but
judging by the Alpha I took part in the
game does a good job of slowly building
up your knowledge base On June 16th
disintegration drops on ps4 PC and Xbox
one
speaking of real-time tactical games
check out Desperados 3 on June 16th in
this one you'll be back in the Old West
running a band of outlaws each member of
the gang has unique traits and good old
stereotypes you know the ones where the
huge hulking guy with an axe he's there
to take on heavy enemies and the
attractive lady has feminine skills to
manipulate the opposition stereotypes
nothing new there
but Desperados 3 isn't going for a
casual audience it prides itself on
hardcore difficulty as you plan and
execute the perfect attack to unveil The
Legend of the John Cooper gang they've
stressed that you'll be outgunned and
outmanned at every moment your tactical
abilities will be tested throughout
coming June 16 on ps4 PC and Xbox one if
you're a switch player you should
consider the expansion for pokemon sword
and shield this is the aisle of armor a
new island with a legendary pokemon
unlocked right away a cup foo a wushu
Pokemon
welcome to 2020 I don't feel like I need
to explain Pokemon I think we were all
raised alongside it so we all get how it
works but if you want more pokemon sword
and shield in your life look out for
this dropping sometime in June
[Music]
and quickly in terms of DLC and other
expansions there's a new season of
Destiny to content dropping on June 9th
another expansion hits the world of
Elder Scrolls online in the shape of
gray more the Elder Scrolls online is
huge game now an online MMO with content
to last another two years of lockdown at
the very least season four of modern
warfare drops in the first week of June
that's another game which has a great
hidden plot and story at the moment in
warzone a nuke bunker has been found and
sightings of Captain Price have been
spotted I'll be looking into that
storyline of modern warfare and how it
combines with warzone very soon
hopefully that's something you would
like to watch and then my Bey fortnight
kicks off season 3 on June 4th and
remember the live event for that season
can be seen this Saturday exciting times
ahead so there we have it 7 games in a
buttload of DLC and extras to note stick
around on the channel for more Last of
Us content and of course more fortnight
shenanigans it looks like the video game
industry is really moving forward with
huge announcements to come over the next
weeks and months it's really an exciting
time to be a gamer watch this space I'm
hoping to cover lots and lots of things
in the future I'll be back next month
with more games and I'll always let me
know when it's free ones around it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]